where we left off in the last video we
had seen what would eventually be called
the first crusades and it was from a
european point of view seemed successful
they were able to take back much of the
holy land for muslim rule the byzantine
empire was able to take back a
significant chunk of the anatolian
peninsula from the seljuk turks who were
also muslim and over the next few
decades this european rule over the holy
land only gets consolidated
this is a zoomed in version of it what
it looked like and you can see these
crusader states that were set up or
these crusader kingdoms and as i pointed
out in the last video even though the
crusades were apparently to help the
byzantines reclaim land as you can see
when the crusaders took the holy land
they for the most part kept it for
themselves and set up these kingdoms
so we are about here we are about here
on our timeline
now as we fast forward a little over a
decade as we get to the middle of the
12th century
you do have the muslims being able to
take back some of the territory in
particular odessa and aleppo and so this
spawns what will eventually be known as
the second crusade and it's really the
second of many crusades
now these are what historians consider
the official numbered crusades but there
were many other crusades in this time
period in roughly this 200-year time
period during the high middle ages you
had crusades against germanic
non-christians in northern europe you
had crusades in spain in order to retake
land from the muslims which they had for
several hundred years what's known as
the reconquista so after aleppo and
edessa were taken you have the second
crusades which end up being quite
unsuccessful and it really doesn't
change what the middle east looks like
but then as you get to the end of the
12th century you have a significant
event
in 1187 you have the sultan salah aden
often known as saladin being able to
retake jerusalem and much of the holy
land remember this is after roughly 90
years of rule of jerusalem by the
western europeans by these crusader
kingdoms
so this
really strikes a chord with the west and
so they decide to launch what what will
be known as the third crusade the third
crusade does make some gains and in fact
this is a crusade that gets significant
buy-in from the kings of western europe
philip ii of france gets involved the
english king richard the first or
richard the lionheart gets involved the
holy roman emperor frederick barbarossa
gets involved when i say holy roman
emperor and the empire you should really
think of medieval germany now as they go
there frederick barbarossa he drowns in
a river this is very dispiriting for his
soldiers so many of them turn around but
philip ii and richard the lionheart are
able to engage
with salah aden and they are able to
gain some land in particular the region
around akra and they're able to get some
concessions from salah aden for unarmed
christian pilgrims to visit the holy
land especially jerusalem now saladin
dies
as we approach the end of the 12th
century
so in the beginning of the 13th century
the fourth crusades get launched and
these are interesting because the
crusaders with the help of venetian
traders they actually engage with the
claimant to the throne of the byzantine
empire with the hope that if they can
help them come back to the throne that
they can provide them the necessary
resources in order to continue on with
the crusades
well they are able to put the claimant
on the throne but then an uprising takes
that claimant down from the throne and
so the crusaders don't get their payment
but they want that payment badly
and so they decide to take
constantinople themselves
and as we mentioned in other videos this
is really the dagger in the heart
between the relationship between the
east and the west we already talked
about the great schism of 1054 but now
you have the west who are followers of
the latin church which eventually gets
known as the roman catholic church they
are sacking constantinople the capital
of the byzantine or the eastern roman
empire the most important city in
eastern christendom and once they
successfully sack the city in bloody
fashion they break up the byzantine
empire amongst themselves and you can
see how they break it up so the fourth
crusade had very little effect on the
actual holy land but it does cause
a temporary end to the byzantine empire
as we get to 1261 constantinople is
retaken by the byzantines but once again
this is the beginning of the end of the
byzantine empire the fact that for
half a century it was taken over by the
west so you can imagine with jerusalem
still in the hands of the muslims many
in the west are not satisfied and in
an interesting event may have occurred
there are some accounts of what is known
as a children's crusade
the stories of the children
or is that a child and there's different
accounts as to exactly the story but
something to the effect that jesus has
told them to go with other pure children
to the holy land and convert the muslims
to christianity
and so then they go on this march and
there's tens of thousands of children
but they don't make it to the holy land
they either die of starvation or they
get sold into slavery on the way
historians today
aren't sure whether it really happened
as that account implies that's why i put
this question mark next to the
children's crusade but regardless of the
actual facts year as we go into the
first quarter of the 13th century
jerusalem remains in the hands of the
muslims
the fifth crusade is launched to retake
jerusalem which is a failure
eventually a sixth crusade is launched
and this is reasonably successful at
retaking some land in the holy land but
shortly that thereafter you have a
non-numbered crusade the barons crusade
that rivals the first crusade in its
success in taking territory and so you
can see after the barons crusade right
over here they're able to take back a
good amount of territory but then in
1244 jerusalem is retaken by the muslims
and then you have the seventh and eighth
and ninth crusades afterwards and you
have these other efforts that are
sometimes called crusades but for the
most part these are unsuccessful and as
we get into the end of the 13th and
early 14th centuries
the holy land falls back under muslim
control
this is a map of the region as we enter
into the 14th century and you can see
that the muslims have retaken not just
the holy land but most of the anatolian
peninsula with only constantinople being
in control of the byzantines
and that lasts until 1453 when the turks
finally take constantinople as well when
you look at the map at the beginning of
this video and look at the map here you
can see that the crusades weren't really
successful at changing the picture in
the holy land there were areas where the
crusades were successful or that
crusader mentality was successful you
can see that now that we're in the 14th
century much of the iberian peninsula
has been taken by christian kingdoms
from the muslims the muslims at this
period are left with only granada so the
reconquista to some degree was
successful it's going to continue until
1492 when the last muslims are expelled
from spain now one thing that i felt
when i study the crusades is it's very
confusing how jerusalem in particular
goes back and forth between different
parties and just to get an overview of
what actually happened
this timeline might be helpful green
shows jerusalem under muslim control red
shows it under christian control so at
the end of the first crusades it
switches hands the christians are in
control all the way until salah adin
takes it back now the muslims are in
control all the way until you get to the
sixth crusade where they're able to take
some territory back in even parts of
jerusalem and especially in the barons
crusades they're able to take
significant territory back but then in
1244 jerusalem is retaken again by the
muslims